Alright, thanks for coming guys.
I just wanted to take a few minutes...
...and talk about some ideas for the marketing strategy this year.
So, if you got one, just throw it out there.
I'd love to hear them.
Yeah, how long is this meeting supposed to last?
The schedule wasn't exactly clear.
We should be out of here in 30.
Is that approximate or...
Hey guys!
Sorry, I'm a couple of minutes late.
I got caught in traffic.
Seven minutes actually.
What's that?
A couple is two.
So, what we're doing is we're just coming up with some ideas for our new marketing strategy so...
...anyone?
I think we should implement Pinterest.
Oh, that's a fun idea!
What about a publicity event in the park?
Interesting.
But, how are you gonna plan around the weather?
What if it rains?
So, we'll party in the rain.
Okay, I just wanna emphasize, there's no bad ideas here.
We're just brainstorming.
Yeah, I'm just really thinking it'll be a huge waste of money...
...to try to plan around the weather.
Yeah! Okay we get your concerns, Nancy!
Thank you!
Hey, where are you all going?
We still have 100% of the things to accomplish.